Dealing with floats across the back
of our knitting can be a challenge,
but we do have lots of options.
Yarns strands that are carried
across the purl side of the
knitting are called floats.
We can take advantage of floats
with the slip stitch technique.
The strands are carried across the
knitting and form decorative patterns
against the purl side of the knitting.
These examples are just one color
slip seen from the purl side.
We'll come back to slip in a minute.
When working with multiple strands of
yarn, especially when working with colors
per row, the floats can get problematic.
In garments, we don't want long
floats that are easily snagged.
So let's talk about some
ways of dealing with them.
First, if you're knitting a
jacket or a coat, a knitted or
fabric lining might be the answer.
For example, by adding fabric
to a blanket, you could use
any multicolor stitch pattern
without worrying about floats.
For a scarf knit it twice as
wide and fold it in half, then
neatly seam up the long edge.
And again, you can use beautiful Fair
Isle designs and hide the floats.
Some knitters will latch up
long floats as they knit.
Just hang the strands, every few rows.
Please consider that this may distort
the stitches on either side of the float.
But try it for yourself.
This is a long-time favorite
method for many knitters
Another technique that some knitters will
use after they're done knitting, is to
hand stitch those long floats in place.
Just take another piece of yarn
and loosely stitch them down.
You'll want to keep your stitching
loose and not distort the design.
In this example, I'm hanging
the long float on a needle
before I knit the next row.
I'm taking care to keep the
needle in working position
just looping the strand over.
When I knit the next row, that strand
just gets woven in and it doesn't knit.
Another idea is to modify
the stitch pattern a bit.
Reduce the floats for this
snowman by adding some snow in
the background, just a few random
stitches can break up long floats.
This stitch pattern might be
better worked as Intarsia.
Isolating just the little foot
without carrying the stitches
to the edge of the knitting.
Makes more sense.
Instead of dealing with those
long floats on the ends.
Here I am canceling the
end needle selection.
So the contrasting yarn isn't
carried to the edge stitches.
Since the working yarn is traveling along
the edge of the motif, instead of the
edge of the knitting, you'll need to be
sure to use a separate strand of yarn
and wrap the stitches between the motif
and the background to prevent holes.
Back to slip stitch.
To add some color to your knitting without
floats, consider multicolor slip or tuck.
Multicolor slip is basically stripes
where selected needles are slipped and
the color is carried to another row.
In this example, the peach color from
this row doesn't knit for the four rows
of the turquoise, the peach stitches
are carried over those turquoise rows,
creating a two color stitch
pattern with no floats.
The knit side is often
used for this technique.
Now you won't be knitting, cute
little snowman or snowflakes, but
this is a method of adding color
without dealing with floats at all.
Back to the lining idea.
Here's a blanket technique
for you to consider.
I knit a blanket like this years ago.
I don't remember who was the designer.
I don't have the original stitch
pattern, but this idea can also be
applied to other stitch patterns.
First, I knit the crayon
panel in Fair Isle.
As you can imagine, there
were lots of floats.
Let's say each crayon section is 40 rows.
When the panel was complete, I didn't
bind off, but I continued knitting
the black color to create a lining.
I knit 40 rows.
I picked up the edge of that
first crayon, knit the row.
Joining the two pieces together.
I knit another 40 rows of lining.
Picked up the stitches from
the edge of the next crayon.
Knit the row.
Again, joining the two pieces together.
I continued doing this until I got to the
cast on edge and the lining was complete.
In other words, I made a sandwich.
Joining at regular intervals,
making a double warm blanket.
And hiding the floats.
You could do this with any stitch pattern.
Think of this as quilting,
where you're joining the two
layers of knitting as you knit.
We have options when knitting and color
incorporate some of these techniques
and don't avoid color because of floats.